Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir schauen auf die 2. Liga, da spitzt sich die Lage zu. Jetzt nach 33 gespielten Spielen. Wir bewerten die Lage und werfen einen Fokus auf den SC Paderborn mit Stephan Simann vom Padercast. Stephan, herzlich willkommen zurück im Rasenfunk.
Ja, hallo Max, freut mich, dass ich mal wieder mit dabei sein kann.
Ja, Paderborn hat es nicht in die 1. Liga geschafft, da habe ich mir gedacht, da machen wir einfach ein Zweitliga-Format, damit wir mal wieder mit dir sprechen können.
Wer weiß, ob man uns nicht vielleicht auch demnächst mal wieder in der 1. Liga begrüßen kann.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Der SC Paderborn, der nähert sich da dem Rasenfunk definitiv an, so kann man es sagen. Ich habe es gerade schon im Intro kurz angesprochen, möchte es aber nochmal gesondert erwähnen. Du bist Teil des Padercasts, du blogst auch auf Schwarz und Blau. Erzähl doch mal den Hörern und Hörern da draußen, warum sollte man unbedingt in den Padercast mal reinhören?
Ich würde fast sagen, weil wir mit der optimistischste Podcast sind, die es irgendwie so gibt, wenn man uns anhört und zwar die erste Folge vor Beginn der Saison. Ich glaube, von uns fünf Leuten der schlechteste Tipp für das Abschließen der Saison hat Basti gegeben mit Platz 8. Ich habe Platz 6 gesagt und ich glaube, die anderen drei haben uns in den Top 3 verortet.
Wahnsinn. Also der optimistischste Podcast – ja, aus sehr einer Fansicht manchmal, aber ihr habt auch schon sehr, sehr viele Folgen produziert und kann ich sehr, sehr empfehlen für alle diejenigen, die sich noch ein bisschen tiefer einhören wollen. Wir wollen auch über Paderborn natürlich sprechen. Hier im Kurzpass lassen uns aber erstmal noch so ein paar andere Spiele abhaken von diesem Spieltag. Da hatten wir unter anderem den ersten FC Köln, der durfte seine Meisterschale, seine Meisterfelge entgegennehmen nach einem 3 zu 5 zu Hause gegen Regensburg. Größter Trost wahrscheinlich der kommende Trainer hat für dieses 5 zu 3 gesorgt auf Regensburger Seite.
Stimmt, heute wurde ja verkündet, wer der Nachfolger wird von Markus Anfang. Aber sonst, ich glaube, Köln ist eh im Partymodus, aber die sind glaube ich ganz froh, dass die Saison vorbei ist und dann ist es glaube ich eigentlich völlig egal. Ich glaube, wenn man schon das Ergebnis sieht, ein 3 zu 5, das ist so ein klassisches, okay, letzten Spieltag, es geht um nichts mehr. Also fallen jetzt auch Tore wie bekloppt. Wobei Köln nicht das erste Mal 3 zu 5 diese Saison verloren hat, aber ja, das ist jetzt so ein Ergebnis. Ich habe mich zwar gewundert, dass da so viele Tore gefallen sind, aber so ganz überraschend ist es halt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und bei der Konstellation, mit der beide Mannschaften reingegangen sind, am Ende wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also Achim Bayer-Lorz, der Trainer vom Jan, wird in der nächsten Saison beim 1. FC Köln Trainer sein. Es gab da interessante Szenen im Interview mit dem Sky-Reporter, hat Toni Schumacher gesagt. Ja, also wenn mein Handy jetzt klingelt, dann kann ich ihn noch live jetzt im Interview verkünden, wer unser Trainer wird. Ich warte nur noch aufs Handy klingen. Tja, hat dann doch noch bis Montag gedauert. Ich weiß nicht, warum man sich dazu dann noch entschieden hat. Aber man weiß jetzt auf jeden Fall, Achim Bayer-Lorz wird den FC in der nächsten Saison trainieren. Jetzt deine Erfahrung nach, jetzt nach diesem Jahr 2. Liga. Für was für ein Fußball steht denn Bayer-Lorz bei Regensburg?
Boah, da erwischt mich fast auf den falschen Fuß, weil ich mit Regensburg echt wenig irgendwie irgendwie gerade verbinde. Also auch wenn ich mich probiere, an die Spiele zurück zu erinnern, die ich gesehen habe, zum Beispiel in Regensburg von Paderborn. Das haben wir zwar verloren, aber so richtig kann ich dir gar nicht mehr sagen, wie ich irgendwie Regensburg jetzt vor Augen habe. Ich könnte dir viel mehr zu Köln erzählen.
Ja, viel mehr zu Köln, das glaube ich. Also Regensburg, ich bin jetzt natürlich auch nicht im Detail drin, aber es fällt auf, also sie haben die viertmeisten Tore erzählt in dieser 2. Liga mit 53 erzielten Toren. Kassiert hat man allerdings 52. Das heißt, auf beiden Enden des Platzes ist viel los bei Regensburg. Vielleicht war da auch dieses Köln-Spiel tatsächlich so ein bisschen simbildlich für die Art und Weise, in der Regensburg spielt. Schon auch viel nach vorne, mit einer sehr geringen Passquote allerdings. Also die schlechteste der ganzen 2. Liga tatsächlich. Das spricht für ein sehr vertikales Spiel. Da sind dann auch viele Ballverluste mit eingepreist. Mehr könnte ich jetzt noch versuchen aus den Zahlen rauszulesen, wäre allerdings noch unseriöser, als das, was ich jetzt gerade schon gesagt habe. Ich glaube, das ist so im Groben das, was man von Regensburg erwarten kann. Und Köln, ja, die sind ja jetzt aufgestiegen und haben es irgendwie geschafft, dieser 2. Liga zu entkommen und werden in der nächsten Saison ja sowieso wieder einen anderen Fußball spielen müssen. Übrigens einen, bei dem vielleicht Markus Anfang mit seiner Umschalt-Taktik vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht gewesen wäre in der 1. Liga. Aber gut, das gucken wir uns einfach ganz in Ruhe an. Dann hatten wir noch ein Spiel, was du definitiv auch mit einem halben Auge verfolgt haben wirst. Denn daran hat sich entschieden, ob Paderborn eventuell schon gleich direkt aufsteigen könnte an diesem 33. Spieltag. Das konnte Paderborn nicht, weil Union Berlin seinerseits 3-0 zu Hause gegen Magdeburg gewonnen hat und damit Magdeburg in die 3. Liga zurück verabschiedet hat. Hättest du da auf eine Sensation gehofft oder war das für dich absehbar, dass Union jetzt wieder in der Spur ist?
Schwierig. Magdeburg hat jetzt auch seit einigen Wochen schon Probleme und das hat sich ja dann doch jetzt mehr oder weniger angedeutet, dass man dann den Gang in die 3. Liga wieder wahrscheinlich antreten muss. Ich finde das sehr, sehr schade, weil man ist ja mit Magdeburg damals hochgekommen, gibt doch recht enge Verbindungen zu den Magdeburger Podcastern. Ich war dann doch erstaunt, wie schwach man sich gegen Ende jetzt gehalten hat. Das war schon, wo ich dachte, okay, ist vielleicht der genau richtige Gegner für Union Berlin um die Zeit, dass die quasi da wahrscheinlich ihre Serie von negativer Erlebnissen brechen können. Weil es gibt, glaube ich, deutlich schwierige Gegner, die man zu der Saisonphase hätte treffen können. Von daher war es, glaube ich, ein bisschen abzusehen, dass Union das Spiel gewinnen wird. Wobei natürlich meine Hoffnung da war, dass Magdeburg da irgendwie noch den letzten Strohhelm zur Relegation irgendwie greifen kann und sich da irgendwie durchsetzt und ich schon hätte gestern feiern können, war leider nicht der Fall. Und so wird es halt im Aufstiegskampf nochmal spannend. Und für Magdeburg tut es mir halt irgendwie doch sehr, sehr leid, weil ich habe die auch einmal live gesehen gegen Darmstadt. Da war ich nämlich im Wochenende zufällig in Magdeburg und habe mir auch mal außer der Reihenspiele in der 2. Liga gegönnt.
Und das war schon – Da habe ich mir Magdeburg-Darmstadt gegönnt. Auch ein Satz, der noch nicht so häufig gefallen ist auf diesem Planeten.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das war auch wirklich ein ganz, ganz unansehnliches Spiel, wo ich schon gedacht habe, oh, das ist halt echt krass, weil gut, man muss sagen, Paderborn hat gegen Magdeburg auch diese Saison kein Spiel gewonnen. Also gegen uns sehen die immer irgendwie ganz gut aus, aber sonst merkt man dann schon wieder immer mehr anscheinend das Selbstbewusstsein runtergegangen ist und man auch in der Offensive quasi keine Gefährlichkeit mehr entwickeln konnte. Und dann hat sich das jetzt halt so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich abgezeichnet, dass es dann runtergeht. Und ja, wie gesagt, ich finde es sehr, sehr schade, weil Magdeburg eigentlich auch, wenn man sich die reisefreudigen Zuschauer ansieht, doch die 2. Liga sehr bereichert hat in meinen Augen.
Ja, zu den Zuschauern gehört auch eine gewisse Unternehmungslust, die auch auf Seiten von Teilen der Union-Fans vorhanden war bei dieser Partie. Da würde ich dann eine kritische Klammer machen wollen, aber wir wollen jetzt nicht die Minderheit auf die Mehrheit übertragen. Das nur mal kurz als Einschub und dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt, was du gesehen hast, das war ja dann noch unter dem alten Trainer und nicht unter Michael Erning, das war Jens Härtel.
Das müsste schon unter dem neuen gewesen sein, das war in der Rückrunde der Spielentschuldigung.
Magdeburg haben wir ja in der letzten Kurzpassfolge schon ein bisschen länger thematisiert und sind da näher drauf eingegangen. Bei Union hatte ich jetzt in dieser Partie den Eindruck, da hat der Spielverlauf maximal geholfen. Also in der achten Minute mit so einem Kopfball nach einer langen Flanke in Führung zu gehen, das hilft natürlich an so einem brisanten Spieltag sehr. Und spätestens ab dem 2 zu 0 hat Union meiner Meinung nach einfach alles genau richtig gemacht. Also hinten nichts zugelassen. Es gab einen Schuss aufs Berliner Tor durch Magdeburg, das ja sowieso schon mit Offensivproblemen die ganze Saison zu kämpfen hat. Ich finde, da hat das Union sehr, sehr gut heruntergespielt, dass es am Schluss dann noch ein 3 zu 0 wird. Das ist natürlich wunderbar. Sebastian Poyter mit seinem zweiten Treffer in der 95. Minute. Aber ich fand, das war ein ruhiger und reifer Auftritt von Union. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, was die genauen Gründe dafür sind. Da müsste man vielleicht das Text tiefer gehen hören, warum das dann auch zum Beispiel in der Vorwoche in Darmstadt nicht so gut geklappt hat. Aber da hatte ich das Gefühl, hier spielt eine Mannschaft, die jetzt genau weiß, was sie noch zu erreichen hat, was sie noch erreichen will und hat das sehr souverän heruntergespielt.
Ja und in Zukunft hat auch die wahnsinnige Heimstärke von Union Berlin, die haben ja wirklich zu Hause nur einmal verloren und das gegen Paderborn. Die sind wirklich auch zu Hause glaube ich echt schwer zu bezwingen, gerade wenn sie noch erst mal in Führung sind.
Was natürlich jetzt dann den Blick auf den 34. Spieltag für Union Berlin lenkt, da reist man zum VfL aus Bochum, für den es um nichts mehr geht, auf der Wellenplatz 10 liegend. Da werden wir jetzt gleich noch dann denke ich mal nochmal ausführlicher sprechen, wenn wir auch die Lage bei Paderborn eingeordnet haben, was denn das mit den Aufstiegsrennen macht und den verschiedenen Konstellationen. Vorher können wir uns aber noch von einer Mannschaft aus dem Aufstiegsrennen verabschieden, die schon vorher nur noch minimale Chancen hatte, nämlich Heidenheim. Beim MSV Duisburg ein 4 zu 3, auch so ein wildes Spiel, aber mit dem anderen Vorzeichen, anders als bei Köln gegen Regensburg, ging es hier für den MSV noch um was und wenn es nur ein würdevoller Abschied aus dieser 2. Liga war.
Zum Thema würdevoll fällt mir dieses wirklich abstruse Eigentor ein, was die Duisburger geschossen haben oder geköpft haben. Das ist, glaube ich, dann so ein bisschen sinnbildlich für, wie wahrscheinlich die Saison gelaufen ist. Also Duisburg steckt ja schon ewig da unten fest. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jemals irgendwie die Abstiegsrennen vernünftig verlassen haben oder anfänglich irgendwie gut reingekommen sind. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, bei Duisburg deutet sich das ein bisschen an, was bei manchen Vereinen halt so passiert, die irgendwie mal ganz oben waren in der ersten Liga und jetzt so Schritt für Schritt sich aus dem Profifußball eventuell verabschieden, weil einfach in dem, in diesem Hifischbecken-Profifußball, kein Platz mehr ist und man jetzt immer so zwischen zweiter und dritter Liga hin und her pendelt und Duisburg nicht unbedingt finanzstark ausgestattet ist. Dass es mich nicht wundern würde, wenn man die längere Zeit nicht in der zweiten Liga wiedersehen, sondern dass sie vielleicht noch einen Gang perspektivisch und noch weiter nach unten antreten. Also ich glaube, das ist auch gerade, wenn man sich die letzten Jahre anguckt, kommt Duisburg langsam in eine kritische Phase, wo du halt nicht guten Gewissens sagen kannst, dass die irgendwann wieder langfristig in der zweiten Liga sich etablieren können. Das wird, glaube ich, ganz, ganz schwer dort. Und ja, dann kommen halt dann noch solche Spiele dazu, die dann wirklich auch dann zeigen, dass es auch dieses Jahr sportlich einfach nicht gereicht hat.
Also nur an vier Spieltagen war in dieser Saison Duisburg nicht auf einem der letzten drei Tabellenplätze platziert in der Liga. Der Abstieg hat jetzt niemanden überrascht. Aber man sieht eben auch, wie die finanzielle Konstitution bei diesen Vereinen ist, die da runtergehen. Also der 1. FC Markeburg zum Beispiel hat ganz offensiv kommuniziert nach dem Abstieg. Es soll jetzt keiner damit rechnen, dass wir direkt wieder aufsteigen. Also frühestens vielleicht in drei Jahren. Das heißt, deren Erwartungsmanagement sieht jetzt schon so aus, dass sie sagen, also wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal wieder in der 3. Liga konsolidieren, um einen neuen Anlauf zu nehmen. Und was Ähnliches kann man sich ja dann beim MSV auch erwarten. Das ist schon ein harter Fall, den man da hat von der 2. in die 3.
Ich glaube sogar ein bisschen mit dem Unterschied, dass man kann das in Markeburg sagen, weil man ja auch schon in der 3. Liga einigermaßen wirtschaftlich gut aufgestellt war. Die haben sich ja damals auch in der Regionalliga noch entschuldet. Und der MSV Duisburg, die werden wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ja wir müssen uns irgendwie konsolidieren. Aber das könnte durchaus dann sein, dass da ähnlich wie bei Lautern eigentlich in der vorgehaltenen Hand gesagt werden muss, wir müssen bald wieder aufsteigen, kostet das, was es wolle. Also ich glaube, da sind sogar die Vorzeichen bei den beiden Absteigern deutlich anders. Ich glaube Magdeburg kann ein paar Jahre aushalten in der 3. Liga, Duisburg glaube ich nicht.
Ja, das ist schon alles einigermaßen dramatisch und kulminiert dann eben in so einem 3 zu 2 Gegentreffer. Nachdem man gerade das 2 zu 2 erzielt hat durch Dustin Bomheuer, war das in der 58. Minute. Am Ende gewinnt das Heidenheim mit 4 zu 3. Niklas Dorsch macht da noch den letzten Treffer. Den werden vielleicht auch der ein oder andere und die ein oder andere da draußen kennen. Für Heidenheim endet damit eine erfolgreiche Saison. Nicht mit dem Aufstieg, aber mit Platz 5 und 52 Punkten in dieser Konstellation, in dieser Liga. Einfach bemerkenswert, was da bei Heidenheim immer vom Ergebnis her, vom Lasterfeld. Das muss man an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz sagen.
Ja, es ist unsympathisch, man Heidenheim finden kann, aber tatsächlich die Arbeit, die da irgendwie auch die letzten Jahre mal geleistet wird, auch unter Trainer Frank Schmidt, der ja quasi Nebenschnatterer, so die Symbolfiguren sind von Heidenheim, das ist eigentlich, da kann man eigentlich gar nicht genug anerkennen. Und auch mir war damals, als wir gegen Heidenheim das Rückspiel hatten, hatte ich echte Angst und dachte, okay, das wird so ein richtiger Gradmesser, ob wir jetzt gegen Heidenheim gewinnen oder nicht. Weil die haben sich auch sportlich halt immer weiter und weiter und weiter entwickelt. Das siehst du bei einigen Mannschaften, die halt im Aufstiegskampf mitgemischt haben, nicht. Die haben dann gegen Ende halt eher immer schlechter gespielt. Und Heidenheim hat eigentlich doch konstant so eine erste Bewegung nach oben. Und da würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn die auch irgendwann mal, wenn die Liga leicht genug ist und keine gesetzten Aufsteiger irgendwie, ja, aus der ersten Liga runterkommen, dass die auch mal vielleicht in die erste Liga aufsteigen.
Ja, das könnte natürlich sein. Also Heidenheim für all diejenigen Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das nicht vor Augen haben, da hängt auch ein Investor mit hinten dran. Und so ein bisschen als Kontrapunkt hat man dann aber einfach diesen Trainer und mit Marc Schnatterer, diesen, ich glaube ja immer noch Kapitän, die gefühlt schon seit mehreren Dekaden bei Heidenheim jetzt das Regiment führen. Ganz so krass ist es natürlich nicht, aber eine dürfte es tatsächlich schon sein in der Saison. Robert Klatze neben Marc Schnatterer, noch einer der entscheidenden Spieler vorne drin, mit 13 Toren, drei Torvorlagen. Standardstärke bei Heidenheim, immer ein Thema. Also da ist so einiges gut gelaufen und führt eben dann zu einer solchen Platzierung. Was uns dann vielleicht zu dem Spiel bringt, was am meisten im Fokus stand an diesem Wochenende. Und das hatte mit beiden beteiligten Mannschaften zu tun. Zum einen mit dem SC Paderborn und zum anderen mit dem Hamburger SV. Und bevor wir gleich länger über den SCP sprechen, lass mal auf dieses Spiel, auch wenn es dir vielleicht etwas schwerer fällt, aus HSV-Sicht blicken. Am Ende steht ein 4 zu 1. Es gab allerdings zwischendurch diese Phase, in der der SCP das 3 zu 0 fast schon etwas leichtfertig nicht geschossen hat. Und dann dieser Anschlusstreffer vom HSV. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, jetzt könnte es sein, dass Hamburg in die Partie noch mal reinkommt. Deckt sich das mit deinen Eindrücken?
Ja, die Angst besteht ja bei Paderborn irgendwie ganz, ganz oft. Wir hatten schon des Öfteren im Verlauf der Saison zwei tore Vorsprünge. Ich erinnere mich an Magdeburg, wo wir, glaube ich, im Hinspiel 2-0 und 4-2 vorne lagen. Und am Ende ging das Spiel 4 zu 4 aus. Und ähnlich ist das auch dann vielleicht jetzt gegen den HSV gewesen, dass ich schon mit Sorgen gemacht habe, okay, das Momentum kann dann plötzlich auf Seiten des HSV sein und plötzlich kippt dann irgendwie auch die Stimmung. Ja, die Spieler verlieren irgendwie quasi dann irgendwie den Faden. Aber ich muss auch gestehen, ich hatte deutlich weniger Angst als vielleicht noch vor einem halben Jahr, weil man hat natürlich mit Paderborn immer diese wahnsinnigen Spektakel in Erinnerungen und sagt, okay, da fallen immer viele Tore auf beiden Seiten. Man verkennt aber dabei, dass man gerade in der Rückrunde sich defensiv deutlich stabilisiert hat. Also ich war vor ein, zwei Spieltagen, waren wir sogar, zählten wir zu den defensiv stärksten Mannschaften in der Rückrundentabelle und wo ich dachte, okay, das muss jetzt nicht irgendwie das Ende heißen, also das jetzt irgendwie, also 2 zu 2 muss nicht zwingend fallen, auch wenn der HSV vielleicht dran war. Aber insgesamt war ich da irgendwie noch einigermaßen optimistisch tatsächlich, was eigentlich auch eher meiner Einstellung zum Fußball widerspricht. Normalerweise immer vom schlechtesten ausgehen, aber man muss ja so gucken, der HSV ging in dieses Spiel mit der Pflicht zu siegen und die waren ja nur nicht unbedingt mit Selbstbewusstsein ausgestattet, weil man ja schon seit etlichen Spielen nicht gewinnen konnte. Und Paderborn hat ja dann auch teilweise echt stark gespielt und wir müssten eigentlich das 3-0 machen, gut dann fällt irgendwie das 2 zu 1, wie es halt oft so ist. Aber eigentlich stand trotz des vielleicht kippenden Momentums irgendwie immer noch die Karten ganz gut für uns.
Also jetzt acht Ligaspiele in Folge für den HSV ohne Sieg, nur drei unentschieden, alles andere verloren und die letzten Niederlagen 0 zu 2 bei Union Berlin, 0 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Ingolstadt, jetzt ein 1 zu 4 beim SC Paderborn. Das führt zu der einigermaßen grotesken Situation, dass in dieser Partie der Hinrundenmeister, nämlich der HSV mit 37 Punkten, auf den Rückrundenmeister, nämlich den SC Paderborn mit 32 Punkten, kann nicht mehr eingeholt werden, auch ein Spieltagvorschluss getroffen ist. Was ja auch zeigt, wo es schief gegangen ist für den HSV, nämlich in der Rückserie. Und jetzt greifen die üblichen Mechanismen. Also ich habe gelesen, Klaus-Michel Kühne hat sich gleich mal wieder gemeldet und hat gesagt, ja ich wollte, dass Wolf gefeuert wird.
Ja, man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass beim HSV einfach keine Ruhe reinkommt. Gerade dieses Ding, wir steigen einmal in die zweite Liga ab und machen irgendwie alles wieder gesund und toll, das scheint nicht so einfach zu funktionieren. Also natürlich war für uns alle der HSV gesetzt als Aufsteiger vor der Saison. Ich glaube, jeder hat gesagt, Köln HSV, wenn souverän, erster und zweiter. Ich hatte auch mit dem anderen HSV gesprochen, es gab auch welche, die ein bisschen pessimistischer waren. Aber eigentlich, wenn alles normal gelaufen wäre, und sie waren ja Hinrundenmeister, dann hätte man eigentlich das locker zu Ende spielen können und wäre souverän aufgestiegen. Was auch immer dann in der Rückrunde passiert ist, das wissen wahrscheinlich die Beteiligten besser als wir, aber irgendwas scheint da gehörig schiefgegangen zu sein. Weil eigentlich die Qualität war da. Ich meine, gut, man hat eine sehr junge Mannschaft, vielleicht spielt das auch eine Rolle. Aber eigentlich hätte man sich das eigentlich nicht mehr nehmen lassen. Und so bin ich tatsächlich gestern extrem erstaunt verwundert gewesen und kann mir eigentlich heute auch nur die Augen reiben, dass wir dieses Spiel da gewonnen haben. Weil eigentlich war vom HSV noch vor einigen Wochen was ganz anderes zu erwarten. Und ich hatte wirklich meine größte Angst vor einigen Wochen, dass der HSV bei uns aufsteigen würde. Und das ist halt bekanntlich nicht passiert, konnte auch nicht mehr passieren in dem Spiel. Aber damit gerechnet hat, glaube ich, keiner.
Ich glaube, es wird uns jetzt nicht möglich sein, hier die Beweggründe für diesen ungewollten Klassenerhalt beim HSV in dieser zweiten Liga – auch wenn es mathematisch noch nicht komplett durch ist, aber de facto wird sich da jetzt nichts mehr dran ändern, aufzuarbeiten. Ich glaube, das können wir zwar hier an der Stelle nicht leisten, aber lass noch mal kurz auf das Spiel zurückkommen. Der HSV logischerweise sehr unter Druck. Man hat auch in der Formation ein bisschen was geändert. Also Santos ist auf der Zehn aufgelaufen. Hinten drin hat Bates als rechter Teil in einer Dreierreihe gespielt und man hat sehr wenig gesehen vom HSV. Also keine Ballsicherheit, viele Ballverluste und vor allem war das Problem alles, was der SC Paderborn auf dem Fuß hatte, gefühlt zumindest, hat Torgefahr entwickelt und der HSV hat es fast gar nicht bis zum Paderborner Tor geschafft. Würdest du da jetzt taktische Gründe anfügen oder glaubst du, am 33. Spieltag bei so einem Spiel müssten wir jetzt nicht mehr mit Taktik anfangen, sondern das war eine Kopfsache, jetzt mal auf diese Partie bezogen?
Ich würde sagen, der Kopf könnte tatsächlich bei dem Fall überwiegen. Man muss ja noch schauen, dass auch der Stammtorwart kurzfristig ausgefallen ist und dann der Ersatztorhüter im Kasten stand. Das sind alles so Sachen, die werden bei Schwächeln im Selbstbewusstsein nicht unbedingt förderlich sein für deine Leistung auf dem Platz. In Zukunft vielleicht auch noch im Hinterkopf, okay, wir haben Paderborn schon zweimal besiegt und das waren zwei Spiele, wo Paderborn eigentlich chancenlos war. Also da war wirklich das 1 zu 0 in der Hinrunde, da hätten wir eigentlich noch viel, viel höher verlieren müssen fast und im DFB-Pokal hatten wir auch keine Chance. Was, glaube ich, so ein bisschen ein Kniff war, womit auch, glaube ich, gar nicht so viele gerechnet haben, ist, dass auf SCP-Seite Klaus Czasula in der Startelf stand, um gerade die Gefährlichkeit von Standards irgendwie zu minimieren beim HSV, weil gerade im DFB-Pokal hat man gelernt, okay, die sind verdammt gefährlich bei Standards, weil beide Tore sind nach einem Standard gefallen und mit Klaus Czasula hast du einen großen Typen dabei, der halt da deutlich die Kopfballstarken Spieler besser irgendwie in den Griff bekommen kann. Und das war, glaube ich, so ein kleiner Kniff, wo man quasi nicht mitgerechnet hat und dann natürlich die Kopfsache irgendwie. Du hast ein Publikum, was mehr oder weniger zwei geteilt ist, irgendwie die Paderborner, die wirklich einfach – also wir schweben ja schon auf Wirke 7, wir hätten auch verlieren können, also völlig egal. Also wenn man das vergleicht, wie es irgendwie vor zwei Jahren uns ging und wie es uns jetzt geht, da hast du ein euphorisiertes Publikum, was irgendwie dann mitgeht und die Mannschaft anfeuert, egal was passiert. Beim HSV, da lebt dann vielleicht sogar die Angst, dich auch auf der Tribüne und du denkst, mein Gott, wir können doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft verlieren, weil dann ist die ganze Saison vorbei. Und ich glaube, diese ganze Gemengelage, die kann dann durchaus dazu führen, dass du halt im Kopf nicht so frisch und klar bist, wie das vielleicht sein solltest. Ja und dann verlierst du halt so ein Spiel und das ist ja dann neben den ganzen, ja vielleicht auch taktischen Fragen, dann einer der Hauptgründe, warum das einfach gestern für den HSV nicht funktioniert hat.
Ja, dann lass mal die Saison vom SC Paderborn ein bisschen einordnen. Du hast es ja gerade schon so ein bisschen angesprochen. Es liegen bewegte Jahre hinter dem SC Paderborn. Ich arbeite das nochmal kurz vor alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das nicht mehr vor Augen haben, auf. Wir springen einfach mal fünf Jahre zurück. Da steigt der SC Paderborn in die 1. Bundesliga auf, unter Andre Breitenreiter. Im Jahr darauf steigt man als Tabellen-18er in die 2. Liga ab. Im Jahr darauf steigt man unter René Müller dann auf Tabellenplatz 18 liegend in die 3. Liga ab. Im Jahr darauf steigt man am Ende dann mit Steffen Baumgart auf dem Trainerpfosten in die 4. Liga ab. Dieser Abstieg wird nicht vollzogen, weil der TSV 1860 München aus der 2. Liga absteigt und Hassan Ismaik nicht bereit ist, entsprechende Garantien für die 3. Liga Lizenz zu hinterlegen. Das heißt, der SCP bleibt von Hassan Ismaiks Gnaden in der 3. Liga und steigt in der Folgesaison dann als 2. Platzierter in die 2. Liga auf. Und jetzt gibt es eben die sehr gute Möglichkeit, entweder direkt aufzusteigen oder über den Relegationsplatz zumindest noch zwei Finalspiele, um den Aufstieg zu haben. Was zur Hölle ist bei euch in Paderborn los?
Ich würde sagen, wir haben den Begriff Fahrstuhlmannschaft komplett neu definiert.
Ja, Fahrstuhlmannschaft auf Koks.
Ja, das ist halt einfach Wahnsinn. Also ich habe ja ironischerweise oder lustigerweise genau in dem Jahr angefangen zu bloggen, wo wir aufgestiegen sind. Ja, aber wahrscheinlich bin ich schuld, ja, weil seitdem ich komme halt auch nicht zur Ruhe. Ich meine, das macht ja auch mit dem Fanleben was, dieses riesige Auf und Ab. Also ich habe vor ein paar Tagen mal Bilder rausgesucht. Ich habe fatalerweise von mir ein Selfie gemacht, nachdem wir in Osnabrück abgestiegen sind in die vierte Liga, wo ich, das ist glaube ich das Bild, es gibt kein Bild, wo ich so tot traurig gucke. Also das wird auch für jeden Fall des Aufstiegs, weil ich mal als Kontrast dieses Bild vielleicht posten, damit man sieht, wie tief am Boden ich eigentlich war. Und jetzt geht es halt irgendwie wieder bergauf und ich glaube, diese ganzen, allein dieser Abschluss konnte schon nicht erklärt werden und auch allein jetzt diese letzten Jahre, wo es jetzt hochgeht unter Steffen Baumgart mit dem Fußball, den habe ich in Paderborn noch nie gesehen und den hat man allgemein, glaube ich, in ganz, ganz vielen Städten noch nie gesehen, kann das glaube ich keiner so richtig erklären, wie es jetzt sein kann, dass wir wirklich da oben irgendwie anklopfen und vielleicht doch noch mal in die erste Liga aufsteigen. Weil ich dachte schon damals, als wir abgestiegen sind, noch mehr Bundesliga werde ich höchst wahrscheinlich nicht erleben, das kommt einfach wahrscheinlich nicht mehr vor. Und jetzt, ja, jetzt steht man irgendwie dann doch ganz, ganz dicht davor, hat selbst in der eigenen Hand und ich hätte gerne mal, auch wenn es dann irgendwie langweilig wird, eine Saison, die wirklich langweilig ist. Ich möchte irgendwann mal, weiß nicht, acht Spieltage vor Schluss soll einfach nichts mehr gehen, weil ich merke so auf der Zielgeraden, dass einem das halt echt fertig macht, ja, weil ich und jetzt die letzten paar Spiele schon kaum noch irgendwie ins, ja, ins Stadion gehen, ohne irgendwie extrem angespannt zu sein. Gerade wenn man jetzt guckt, wir haben ja am 32. Spieltag in Bielefeld am Freitagabend verloren. Ich dachte, okay, jetzt wollen wir im Verlauf des Spieltages den zweiten Platz abgeben. Stattdessen verlieren alle anderen auch, ja, und du bleibst immer noch zweiter. Jetzt verteidigen wir diesen zweiten Platz und haben den dritten sicher und stehen da, wo, ja, wo ich uns vor zwei Jahren zumindest nicht gesehen habe und wünsche eigentlich den, ja, diesen gestressten Fansälen und ich schließe mich da eindeutig mit ein, endlich mal eine ruhige Saison. Aber ich habe ein bisschen die Angst, die werden wir auch nächste Saison nicht erleben.
Ja, da ist irgendwas im Paderborner Grundwasser oder ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Was macht denn der SCP aus deiner Sicht anders als andere Vereine? Denn Zufall kann das ja jetzt inzwischen nicht mehr sein. Man steigt nicht zufälligständig auf und ab.
Also sagen wir mal so, die Abstiegssachen kann man erklären, dass man einfach fatales Missmanagement irgendwie betrieben hat. Also gab es so interessante Konstellationen, dass man sich Stefan Effenberg als Trainer ans Haus geholt hat, dass man den Anspruch hatte, schnell wieder in die 1. Liga aufzusteigen, was aber vielleicht schon ein leicht größer Wahnsinn war. Und dann kommst du dann irgendwann, wenn du absteigst, in eine negative Strudel hinein. Dann sind im Umfeld alle schlecht drauf, dann sind die Fans schlecht drauf und immer ein paar Spieler nimmst du ja mit in die neue Saison. Und die transportieren vielleicht irgendwie diese schlechte Laune mit, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall ist es ja nicht normal, dass du halt so konsequent absteigst. Dass wir jetzt so wieder nach oben geschossen sind, das hängt, ich würde sagen, zu 80 Prozent mit der Personalien Markus Krösche zusammen. Der wurde kurz bevor wir quasi abgestiegen sind in die Regionalliga als Manager Sport installiert und war halt der, auf den eigentlich alle gewartet haben. Markus Krösche hat 13 Jahre lang in Paderborn ja seine Spielerkarriere verbracht. Der war auch nirgendswo anders. Der ist auch mit uns aufgestiegen, hat dann zur Erstligasaison aufgehört und als Trainer der 2. Mannschaft fungiert. Ist dann über den Umweg bei Leverkusen als Co-Trainer dann wieder zu uns zurückgekommen und hat halt dann als erste Amtshandlung mit Steffen Baumgart installiert und halt dann Spieler aus Klassen verpflichtet, wo man nicht unbedingt drauf kommt. Man hat zum Beispiel Jimmy Antvijaj aus der Regionalliga beim TSG Sprock-Hövel gefunden. Also nicht unbedingt ein Verein, den man auf dem Zettel hat. Oder, wer fällt mir noch ein? Also man geht konsequent irgendwie. Man hat kürzlich Kai Prüger geholt von Rot-Weiß Essen, der auch echt gut eingeschlagen ist für jemand, der gerade aus der Regionalliga kommt. Also man fischt so ein bisschen in den unteren Ligen aus der Gegend. Man experimentiert auch ein bisschen, hat zwei, drei Spieler auch von weiter hergeholt, auch jetzt am 2. aus den USA. Und etabliert aus irgendwelchen Gründen hier gnadenlosen Offensivfußball, der auch einfach funktioniert. Und da steckt dann wieder Steffen Baumgart irgendwie mit drin, der halt ein Fußballspieler ist, der irgendwie doch phänomenal und erhaltsam ist.
Lass noch mal kurz bei den Neuzugängen bleiben, bevor wir dann über Steffen Baumgart auch noch kurz sprechen wollen. Denn das ist ja wirklich interessant, wenn man sich da eben die Vereine anguckt, wo die Spieler herkommen. Du hast jetzt ein paar Beispiele schon genannt, aber du hast ja auch Cazula, der eben vom Halleschen FC kam. Du hast Luca Pfeiffer von den Stuttgarter Kickers. Wenn wir ein paar Spielzeiten nach hinten gehen, dann sehe ich dann Zugänge von Fürstenwalde, Spraghövel hast du schon genannt, aus der Zweiten von Wolfsburg, von BFC, Dynamo, von den Kickers Offenbach, von Grödig, wo ich jetzt nicht mal wüsste, was da eigentlich jetzt, ob das ein FC, ein SV oder eine Spielvereinigung Grödig ist oder gar Dynamo Grödig. Keine Ahnung. Jetzt würde ich vermuten, dass Paderborn nicht über ein riesiges Netz an Scouts verfügt. Ist das dann der One-Man-Show von Markus Grösche oder woher kommt allein das Wissen?
Ich glaube, das ist definitiv größtenteils eine One-Man-Show mit Markus Grösche. Der hat zwar auch natürlich seinen Kaderplaner, mit dem er auch Sachen gemeinsam macht, aber Markus Grösche ist, ich glaube, überragend vernetzt in der ganzen Branche. Er kennt offensichtlich viele Leute und man merkt so ein bisschen, wie wichtig er ist, wenn man sieht, wie die Fans im Internet reagieren, wenn jetzt Markus Grösche mit anderen Vereinen in Verbindung gebracht wird. Er selbst hat einen Vertrag bis 2022 hier und war jetzt im Verlauf der Endphase der Saison bereits bei Hannover, Nürnberg, Schalke, Leipzig in Verbindung und auch teilweise vorstellig. Also ich glaube, man kann ihn nicht halten, weil er einfach zu gute Arbeit gemacht hat und er quasi der ist, der für diese wahnsinnig erfolgreichen Spielzeiten jetzt steht. Und allein die Reaktion, wie panisch die Leute werden, wenn gesagt wird, dass er gehen könnte und ich vermute auch, er wird gehen, wenn wir nicht aufsteigen, die zeigen halt, wie wichtig er ist und wie gut er auch den Verein kennt. Ich meine, du musst ja A, die Connections haben, aber B, auch vielleicht verstehen, wie dieser Verein funktioniert. Und ich glaube, er hat auch einigermaßen freie Hand, weil alle wissen, dass der sich halt quasi auskennt. Er ist halt Paderborner. Er ist nicht gebürtiger Paderborner, aber er gehört halt irgendwie zu Paderborn. Und deswegen ist das tatsächlich ein Kopfmonopol, was, glaube ich, nur sehr schwer gerade abzubauen ist, weil er kein anderer versteht das so gut, was er hier gerade im Paderborn macht, als er.
Der Kicker schrieb vor drei Tagen, dass Rasenballsport Leipzig mit Markus Krösche nur noch um die Details vorhanden würde. Ob das jetzt so kommt, das gucken wir mal, aber das zeigt ja, da gibt es schon zumindest fortgeschrittene Gespräche. Ob das dann auch zu einer Entscheidung seinerseits führt, werden wir ja dann sehen. Und ob das dann auch außerhalb von Paderborn funktioniert auch. Wie ist es denn, um die finanziellen Mittel beim SCP bestellt? Man muss ja irgendwie auch, selbst wenn man aus den unterklassigen Ligenspieler holt, das größte Problem für Vereine im Falle eines Abstiegs ist ja, dass so viel mehr an Geld, Einnahmen fehlen, auf der anderen Seite nicht immer die Gehaltszettel im gleichen Sinne schwinden und man dann so in finanzielle Engpässe kommt.
Ja, also aktuell ist der Verein definitiv verschuldet und hat auch am Plan, diese Schulden quasi abzubauen. Das sind so ein bisschen halt diese Lasten, die man dann rumtrinkt, wenn du dann zwei Jahre in der dritten Liga spielst. Weil du hast es gerade schon gemeint, du hast da halt ein Etat, der ist halt nicht großartig kleiner, weil die dritte Liga ist halt auch sehr, sehr stark besetzt und du bist gerade als SC Paderborn auch gezwungen, irgendwann aufzusteigen, weil du kannst einfach nicht in der dritten Liga überleben, du bist einfach zu sehr abhängig von den Fernsehgeldern. Diese Altlasten, die trägt man jetzt noch so ein bisschen mit. Man hat allerdings vor, ich glaube vor gut einem Jahr ausgegliedert, also man hat die Profi-Abteilung in der GmbH und Co. KG ausgegliedert und möchte auch…
Na dann wird ja jetzt alles gut.
Selbstverständlich. Genau, das haben wir bei 68 München sehr, sehr gut miterlebt. Ne, also das ist halt perspektivisch, hat man da offensichtlich Pläne, wie man sich irgendwie auch entschulden möchte. Allerdings ist man definitiv abhängig davon, mindestens in der 2. Bundesliga zu spielen. Man darf vielleicht ab und an mal nach oben oder unten ausrutschen, aber ohne Zweitliga-Fußball gibt es im Paderborn, glaube ich, keinen Profifußball und aktuell ist man finanziell, hält man das. Also man kann mit diesen Schulden irgendwie auch gerade leben, aber wenn es mal runtergehen würde länger, dann gibt es auch riesige Probleme und das wird man dann wahrscheinlich eher ein schlechteres Ende nehmen. Ich könnte noch dazu sagen, also man hat ja vielleicht mit Paderborn auch immer Möbelhaus Finke in Erinnerung, dass man sehr, sehr stark da gesponsert wird. Wilfried Finke ist ja Anfang des Jahres verstorben, hat kurz vorher auch sein Präsidentenamt abgegeben und auch seine Möbelgruppe verkauft, wo man ein bisschen drauf schließen kann, okay, da war vielleicht auch klar, dass er nicht mehr lange irgendwie dem Verein zur Verfügung steht. Und deswegen ist man jetzt auch quasi gezwungen, auch sich komplett zu emanzipieren und selbst einen Weg zu finden, wie man sich irgendwie in diesem Fußballbusiness halten möchte. Also das ist dieses Ding mit, ja, eigentlich ohne finke Gewehre Paderborn nicht, wo man jetzt ist, aber diesen Joker, den können wir fort dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ziehen, denn jetzt muss man quasi solide arbeiten, wie es dann andere Vereine vielleicht auch vormachen. Weil die Strahlkraft eines, von anderen Vereinen hat der SCP definitiv nicht. Ich glaube, das ist realistisch genug zu sagen, man wird hier nicht irgendwie ganz, ganz viele Sponsoren anziehen können, weil die den SCP als sehr, sehr attraktive Marke wahrnehmen. Da gibt es andere Vereine, die gerade in Nordrhein-Westfalen prädestinierter sind.
Also der Joker-Geldgeber, der liegt jetzt wieder im Ablagestapel. Dann haben wir den Joker-Sportdirektor. Da sind wir uns noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie lange der dem SCP erhalten bleiben wird. Bleibt ja noch der Joker-Trainer, der einen Fußball spielen lässt, der sich deutlich von vielem abhebt, was man sonst in der 2. Liga sehen kann. Wofür steht Steffen Baumgart?
Offensichtlich für gnadenlosen Offensiv-Fußball lieber 4 zu 3 als 1 zu 0 gewinnen. Du merkst das auch auf dem Platz. Zumindest gab es Phasen, gerade auch in der 3. Liga-Saison, da führst du irgendwie schon 4 zu 0 und die machen halt noch einfach weiter. Ich meine, sinnbildlich ist, dass bei uns im Podcast seit zwei Jahren der Andreas immer 4 zu 0 getippt hat für den SCP und wie eigentlich jedes verdammte Ergebnis irgendwie durch hat, wir haben irgendwie 7 zu 1 gewonnen, 6 zu 0, 6 zu 2. Nur dieses 4 zu 0 ist letztens erst vor ein paar Wochen gegen Duisburg gefallen, aber wirklich, wir haben zwei Jahre lang gewartet, dass wir in Anführungsstrichen nur 4 zu 0 gewinnen, weil die hören einfach nicht auf, Fußball zu spielen. Das hat man auch ganz gut damals im Westfalenpokal erlebt. Da liegst du 5-0 vor, du machst trotzdem weiter, am liebsten zweistellig. Also Steffen Baumgart, der möchte, dass quasi immer auf bemehrt hohe gespielt wird, er lässt auch alles behutsam von hinten aufbauen. Also es ist nicht so, dass der Torwart irgendwie lange Abschläge nach vorne und dann gucken wir, was passiert. Nein, da wird wirklich ganz von hinten quasi über die Innenverteidiger nach vorne aufgebaut, was du auch in Paderborn noch nicht so beim Publikum teilweise etabliert hast, weil die dann doch irgendwie dann diesen Schreckmoment im Stadion haben, wenn dann irgendwie das sehr, sehr knapp aussieht. Aber das ist halt alles inzwischen einstudiert und etabliert und wir kriegen halt keine Gegentore auf, wenn wir irgendwie früh angelaufen werden, weil da doch inzwischen auch eine enorme Ballsicherheit teilweise da ist. Und wir dann natürlich noch ein paar überragende Einzelspieler haben und dann kann man dann so einen Fußball entwickeln, wie wir ihn jetzt entwickelt haben, der, glaube ich, deutschlandweit für Furore gesorgt hat in diesem Jahr.
75 geschossene Tore nach 33 Spielen, 47 kassierte Tore. Da ist immer viel los, wenn der SCP in irgendeinem Stadion in dieser Republik zum Anstoß schreitet. Wer sind denn so die individuell herausragenden Spieler, die du gerade schon angedeutet hast?
Also ganz klar, auf Nummer eins ist Philipp Klement. Den haben wir aus der quasi Reservamannschaft von Mainz geholt, wobei er auch manchmal Erstligaeinsätze hatte. Und der ist ja technisch und taktisch wirklich überragend. Also das ist ein Spieler, wenn wir aufsteigen, den kannst du auch nicht halten, weil der hat wirklich eine enorme Spielintelligenz. Also der spielt Pässe, der hat selbst extrem gute Freistoßfähigkeiten und ist halt auch selbst torgefährlich. Ich glaube, er ist aktuell immer noch unser bester Offensivmann, hat die meisten Tore in dieser Saison gemacht. Genau, und es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass der bei Mainz quasi keine, also sich nicht irgendwie nicht etablieren konnte. Bei uns hat er einen Riesenschritt gemacht und man ist glaube ich aktuell auch sehr, sehr abhängig irgendwie von seiner Kreativität und von seinem Spiel, weil er wirklich diese Mannschaft auf ein noch mal anderes Level irgendwie hebt. Und wie gesagt, er wird sehr, sehr schwer zu halten sein.
Ich habe eine These dazu, warum er bei Mainz 05 nicht zur Geltung kam, weil die damals die 10er-Position noch nicht so offensiv besetzt hatten. Die Umstellung auf Raute, da hätte Klément – gut, er hätte mit Boetsis jetzt auch einen guten Konkurrenten gehabt, aber da hätte Klément wahrscheinlich sehr gut reingepasst. Da ist er einfach sehr, sehr stark in der Zentrale. Vielleicht kommt das daher, dass er damals bei Mainz nicht so gefragt war. Und jetzt kann er eben dann Paderborn aufblühen. Richtig.
Genau, ein anderer Spieler, den man auch auf jeden Fall nennen muss, ist Jamilo Collins, den wir – ich weiß gar nicht, wann wir ihn geholt haben – ist ja erst eine Saison da. Ich glaube schon, der zumindest auf der linken, auf der linksverteidiger Position spielt und sich bei uns wahnsinnig gut gemacht hat. Und zwar so gut, dass er jetzt auch nigereanischer Nationalspieler geworden ist und da auch wirklich eine gute Leistung bringt, auch in der Startelf. Dort stand bei diversen Länderspielen in diesem Jahr und im letzten Jahr. Und der wirklich da auf der linken Seite einfach einen extrem guten Job macht. Also das ist auch ein Spieler, wo man sagt, okay, der wird sehr, sehr schwer zu halten sein, wenn man nicht aufsteigen sollte. Und dann auf jeden Fall würde ich noch als ein Spieler, der eine große Schwankungsbreite in der Leistung hatte, auch Bernard Tepetainen, der von Schalke's U23 gekommen ist, der wirklich teilweise echt überragende Spieler abliefert, extrem torgefährlich ist, auch einen gewaltigen Schuss hat, aber ganz, ganz oft – naja, also der ist ja sehr heißblütig, also den kannst du, glaube ich, ganz gut provozieren. Den musst du auch manchmal wirklich zurückhalten, dass er sich nicht den blöden gelben Karten abholt. Aber der wird halt auch oft gefaut, weil er halt auch teilweise echt schwer zu bremsen ist, weil er wirklich freigeschnell ist und halt, ja, nicht ohne Grund, er hat, glaube ich, Schalke nur für eine Rückkaufoption für ihn. Also der ist wirklich jemand, der hat sein Potenzial, was er, glaube ich, damals schon hatte, hier nochmal gehörig weiterentwickelt. Und ja, der wird auch schwer zu halten sein, wie die anderen beiden, die ich gerade schon genannt habe.
Jetzt gucken wir mal auf den 34. Spieltag voraus und da sehen wir, Union Berlin wird in Bochum spielen und der SCP in Dresden. Paderborn hat einen Punkt Vorsprung vor Union, das heißt, wenn man das gleiche Ergebnis erzielt wie Union Berlin, dann ist man direkt aufgestiegen, wenn man gewinnt, dann sowieso. Was sind jetzt so deine Gedanken mit Blick auf den 34. Spieltag? Welches Szenario hättest du für am wahrscheinlichsten?
Na gut, am wahrscheinlichsten ist natürlich, dass Union und Paderborn beide gewinnen. Also ich glaube, da führt die aktuelle Tabellenkonstellation und auch der Zwang zu gewinnen irgendwie nicht vorbei, dass man das irgendwie prognostiziert. Man sieht, dass Bochum jetzt am Wochenende gegen St. Pauli halt nur 0-0 gespielt hat und dass Dresden sogar 3-0 in Kiel verloren hat, wo vielleicht auch bei beiden Mannschaften, die noch aufsteigen können, die Hoffnung ist, dass die Gegner vielleicht schon ein bisschen im Sommerpausenmodus sind, wobei natürlich auch das Gegenteil sein kann, dass du komplett verkrampft bist und dich deutlich schwerer tust. Unter normalen Umständen muss eigentlich Paderborn gar nicht nach Bochum gucken, weil man gerade einen gehörigen Lauf hat. Man hat von den letzten Spielen das Einzige gegen Bielefeld verloren und sollte eigentlich auch gegen Dresden, die entgegen das vielleicht erwartbaren gar nicht so heimstark sind. In der Heimtabelle sind die auf Platz 10. Das könnte eigentlich dafür sprechen, dass man da eigentlich souverän gewinnt. Und wenn es nach mir geht, natürlich zur Halbzeit am liebsten schon 13.0 vorne liegen, damit war…
Aber das heißt ja bei Paderborn auch nichts.
Stimmt, das heißt natürlich nichts. Aber dass man vielleicht schon ein bisschen in der zweiten Halbzeit feiern kann, das wäre halt der normale Ausgang. Ich meine, klar, du kannst halt nie vorhersehen, was passieren wird. Und natürlich kann es sein, dass irgendwie Union nach zwei Minuten schon irgendwie 1.0 führt und die Ergebnisse in Dresden angezeigt werden und die Spieler dann irgendwie verunsichert sind, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Aber unter normalen Umständen sollten eigentlich beide marschieren und dann Platz zwei und drei sich halt entsprechend weiter aufteilen, wie es gerade aufgeteilt ist. Und wenn nicht, dann ist mir das vielleicht sogar – ich würde nicht sagen, egal – aber dann hat Paderborn immer noch die Möglichkeit, über die Relegation aufzusteigen. Und selbst wenn das nicht klappt, dann hat man halt irgendwie doch eine Saison gespielt, mit der man nicht vorher gerechnet hat. Und natürlich möchte ich jetzt auch aufsteigen, aber wenn es dann irgendwie am Ende doch schief geht, dann ist es – also es gibt Schlimmeres aktuell. Also ich habe da, wie gesagt, vor zwei Jahren war das eine ganz, ganz andere Saisonende, was ich da erlebt habe. Und ja, lieb wäre es, wenn wir es aufsteigen. Und wenn nicht, dann gucken wir halt, wie wir dann vielleicht über die Relegation das Ticket auch noch lösen können. Weil ich glaube, Stuttgart ist nicht unbedingt unmachbar. Also die Relegation 1. und 2. Liga ist dieses Jahr, ich würde sagen, nicht so favoritmäßig gesetzt, wie es vielleicht die letzten Jahre war.
Ja, mal gucken, wie sich das weiter gestaltet. Wir haben uns ein bisschen verplappert, aber ich wollte mir auch einfach diesen größeren Kontext dieser wahnsinnigen Paderborn-Saison noch ein bisschen von dir einordnen lassen. Lass noch kurz auf den Tabellenkeller gucken, denn jetzt haben wir die oberen Tabellenplätze eingeordnet. Unten hat sich aber auch noch etwas getan. Magdeburg und Duisburg beide abgestiegen, haben wir schon erwähnt. Warum sind beide abgestiegen? Weil der FC Ingolstadt auch gegen Darmstadt 98 zu Hause mit 3 zu 0 gewinnen konnte, damit den Relegationsplatz schon sicher hat und noch viel besser, dadurch, dass Sandhausen zu Hause gegen Bielefeld mit 0 zu 3 verloren hat. Gibt es sogar jetzt noch die kleine Möglichkeit, für den FC Ingolstadt an Sandhausen vorbeizuziehen und Sandhausen in die Relegation zu schicken? Ingolstadt fährt nach Heidenheim, Sandhausen zu Jan Regensburg. Wie blickst du auf diese Keller-Situation?
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich habe da sehr, sehr wenig Emotionen. Das sind ja so beide so diese Klischee-Matschaffen, wo man immer sagt, wegen denen bist du irgendwie nicht unbedingt gerne in der 2. Liga und auch ich hatte irgendwie den insgeheimen Wunsch, dass eigentlich beide absteigen, weil beide fehlen mir auch noch von der Liste von Auswärtsstadien, die ich besuchen muss und dachte, wenn die absteigen, dann kriege ich die 2. Liga fast automatisch voll. Den Gefallen tun mir die beiden Teams anscheinend nicht und ich glaube, ja, beide haben ja mehr oder weniger einen Lauf. Ich meine, das ist ein Tausendslauf, wurde jetzt so ein bisschen gebremst, aber ich glaube nach wie vor, dass beide ja gerade auf einem doch recht hohen Niveau irgendwie spielen und trotzdem ich nicht damit gerechnet hätte, dass Ingolstadt nach dem Trainerwechsel irgendwie noch mal jetzt was reißt. Aber gut, vielleicht kann man sich täuschen. Bin ich gespannt, wie das endet, aber ich wag da irgendwie keine Prognose, außer vielleicht auch da, wenn es halt normal läuft, sollten eigentlich beide gewinnen, weil beide gerade stabil genug sind und man auch mit Heidenheim und Regensburg halt zwei Gegner hat. Ja, für die geht es halt um nichts. Ich meine, gut, man spielt halt auswärts, das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen der Nachteil für beide Teams. Ganz lustig, dass alle Teams für die so was geht, nur auswärts spielen. Aber wenn du mich also fragen würdest, wem ich es mehr wünsche und wem nicht, dann hatte ich dann nicht meine Antwort. Also ich glaube, so eine Relegation Wiesbaden gegen Ingolstadt, das hat schon was. Ich meine, das ist, glaube ich, das Duell, was am wenigsten polarisiert, wobei ich da auch eine klare Perferenz habe. Ich möchte sehr gerne, dass Wiesbaden aufsteigt. Aber da muss man mal gucken, wie das passiert. Aber wie gesagt, wenn es normal läuft, gewinnen einfach beide. Und am Ende muss Ingolstadt in die Relegation. Und wenn nicht, dann tut sich da vielleicht auch nochmal was. Aber ich würde auch darauf tippen, dass die beiden gewinnen.
Also ein völlig irrer Schlussspurt von beiden. Der SV Sandhausen hat aus den letzten sechs Spielen fünf gewonnen und eins unentschieden gespielt. Das heißt, seit sechs Spielen ungeschlagen. Und beim FC Ingolstadt kann man die Serie sogar noch größer machen. Entschuldigung, ich habe es genau verkehrt rum gesagt. Das war natürlich – ich dachte mir gerade schon, das passt doch gerade gar nicht – Ingolstadt waren die mit den fünf Siegen und einem Unentschieden in den letzten sechs Spielen. Bei Sandhausen kann man nämlich die Serie sogar noch länger fassen. Da sind es jetzt aus acht Spielen sechs Siege und zwei Unentschieden gewesen. Aber halt auch dieses 0 zu 3 zu Hause jetzt gegen Bielefeld, das hat einfach richtig wehgetan. Man hätte nur ein Pünktchen, hätte zumindest schon mal mehr Sicherheit gegeben. Mit einem Sieg hätte man sich auf jeden Fall sicher gerettet. Da ist so ein bisschen die Pustel ausgegangen gegen einen Gegner, der das in diesem Spiel sehr sehr souverän heruntergespielt hat, fand ich Bielefeld. Das hat mich auch so ein bisschen erinnert an das Bielefeldspiel gegen Paderborn, auch wenn das natürlich andere Vorzeichen waren. Aber die haben, wenn Bielefeld nicht den größten Druck hat, so sind sie mir jetzt zumindest aus der Ferne betrachtet in dieser Saison immer wieder aufgefallen, dann kann das schon sein, dass sie so ein Spiel eigentlich relativ gut runterspielen. Dann haben die eine gute Qualität, die haben eine gute Grundstruktur in der Mannschaft. Und so haben sie es jetzt eigentlich bei beiden Spielen gemacht, sowohl gegen Paderborn als jetzt auch in Sandhausen.
Genau, die sind ja auch nicht ohne Grund auch auf Platz 2 in der Rückrundentabelle. Also die Rückrundentabelle ist quasi fest in ostwestfälischer Hand. Ja, so ist das dann halt.
Es ist unglaublich. Weitere Ergebnisse, die wir jetzt hier nur kurz genannt haben wollen. Kiel 3 zu 0 gegen Dresden haben wir kurz vorhin schon kurz angesprochen. Und St. Pauli hat gegen Bochum 0 zu 0 gespielt. Fürth hat sich mit einem Pünktchen in Aue den Klassennaheit gesichert. Da sind auch große Kleeblätter von den Herzen gefallen, dass man da jetzt sicher sein kann und auf jeden Fall planen kann. Das heißt, es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Mannschaften, die sehr entspannt auf diesen 34. Spieltag guckt. Aber auch die besprochenen vier Paderborn, Union Berlin, Ingolstadt und Sandhausen, die sehr, sehr angespannt auf die Auswärtsspiele der jeweils anderen blicken. Und dann gucken wir doch mal, was mit Paderborn passiert und ob wir uns, Stephan, dann auch im nächsten Jahr in der Schlusskonferenz zur 1. Liga hören. Ich bin ja sehr gespannt.
Ich würde mich sehr darüber freuen, wenn es passieren würde. Und ich hoffe halt, dass ich dann in einer Woche dann am Montag den Herr Kater meines Lebens habe und nicht aufstehen kann, weil es einfach ein sehr, sehr geiler Trip nach Dresden gewesen sein wird.
Und dann kannst du zum Wiederentnüchtern, kannst du dann den Kurzpass hören, der dann aufgezeichnet werden wird in der nächsten Woche. Auch wenn ich noch nicht weiß, ob es am Montag selbst passiert.
Da freue ich mich sehr drauf.
Aber selbst wenn er am Mittwoch rauskäme, wärst du ja da immer noch entnüchterungswürdig, vermute ich.
Hörst wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das war Stephan Simann, Ed Schwarz und Blau auf Twitter vom Padercast. Stephan, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Und euch lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir hören uns nach dem nächsten Zweitligaspieltag und natürlich auch nach dem Erstligaspieltag. Wir sind ja hier im Rasenfunk. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao!